ser título consecutivo quinto de los
últimos siete años es una etapa mágica
pero que además es la continuidad de lo
que ya ha venido siendo Pep Guardiola
tres veces campeón en Alemania tres
veces campeón en España
qué Qué representa la figura de este
hombre en este momento histórico para el
city pues Omar es un nombre de 52 años
que revolucionó el fútbol y yo diría y
saqué así cinco grandes aspectos que
podemos destacar de esto lo primero es
la coherencia y lealtad a una idea él
siempre ha creído en una forma y una
manera tanto de entrenar como ver el
fútbol que la ha digamos impuesto en
cada uno de los equipos en los que ha
ido con muy buenos resultados Eso sí esa
idea se ha ido mejorando y le ha ido
adaptando de acuerdo al contexto para mí
la segunda parte es que es un entrenador
que siempre ha puesto en valor lo que le
han enseñado sus entrenadores desde que
era jugador él tiene como gran maestro y
creo que a partir de ahí es que empieza
a evolucionar este juego la tercera es
la obsesión porque sus equipos tengan la
pelota y no es una tendencia de pelota
como todo el mundo la cree que es
simplemente estética él cree que tener
la pelota hace que está está primero más
cerca el gol pero también porque tener
la pelota hace que mueva las estructuras
rivales y poder hacer daño con la pelota
la cuarta es esta idea Clara y un
concepto digamos que siempre muy estable
pero los sistemas son flexibles los
equipos saben a lo que juega Pep
Guardiola pero no saben que se van a
encontrar cada vez que se que se
enfrentan a él en el campo y eso es muy
interesante él siempre ha hecho a sus
jugadores mejores porque los hace
cambiar de roles o los pone en
posiciones que no son habituales y
siempre ha logrado que sus
individualidades brillan recordemos el
falso 9 de Messi y todo este tipo de
estructuras que lo que hacen es
desestabilizar al rival pero sobre todo
que sus individualidades a pesar de que
tácticamente podría pensarse que son muy
estrictos les da la libertad creativa
para que ellos estén ahí y luego es que
es un líder indiscutible
en esta temporada en el que el city no
tuvo un muy buen rendimiento en la
Premier en la primera ronda después hoy
destacaban en el país que me pareció muy
interesante como después de ese partido
que el remonta ante tottenham el dice
públicamente que le parecía que sus
jugadores no tenían pasión es decir que
también es un entrenador que sabe
liderar y intentar mover desde el punto
de vista emocional las respuestas de los
futbolistas esto es toca su orgullo y
sobre todo los mantiene con esa ambición
competitiva que es fundamental a la hora
de competir por todos estos títulos como
lo mencionabas y con una vocación
incluso de sacrificio que hemos visto
por ejemplo en el caso de greenlish que
ha estado cumpliendo una función
completamente distinta a la que uno
esperaría de él Claro que sí grillis o
Bernardo Silva jugando de extremos muy
pegados a la raya eso en el fútbol
posicional para él es muy importante
pero sobre todo es que un buen
entrenador lo que tienes que convencer Y
cómo convence cuando después de él les
dice en el entrenamiento eso pasa en la
cancha Y creo que hemos visto pues una
de las mejores versiones de este City
rápidamente preguntamos por estas dos
objetivos que todavía le quedan la F y
cop y la Champions Pues yo creo que está
todo muy dado esto es fútbol cualquier
cosa puede pasar lo primero es que ha
gestionado muy bien la plantilla
obviamente Chelsea y vimos que ese
equipo ve que podría decirse del City
tiene la misma idea la misma manera
clara de jugar y esto mantienen
competencia todos sus jugadores lo
siguiente que fue interesante fue ver
cómo gestionó los 180 minutos de la
serie Real Madrid en el primer partido
en el Bernabéu el controló las
situaciones él parecía no que se quedaba
corto en ese resultado luego vimos en el
etihad que dobló las apuestas que fue un
equipo totalmente ofensivo que no
permitió las transiciones Y eso Lo que
implica es entender que también la
evolución y la experiencia en el city le
da la manera de poder gestionar estas
dos finales que le quedan y luego
pues yo creo que si bien es muy
complicado
analizar lo que lo que va a pasar en
estos dos encuentros siento que es muy
difícil encontrarle puntos bajos a este
City que emocional futbolística y en
todos los aspectos está muy fuerte